[Musique]
un million de bébés naissent chaque
année au niger
ça fait 2740 bébé par jour la moitié de
ces bébés est un défi ça veut dire que
1370 filles naissent au niger chaque
jour si on suit l'agenda de l'union
africaine 2063 notre le moment où on
espère que l'afrique sera dans la
meilleure condition possible dans 44 1
ça voudrait dire qu'il y aura 20 2
millions si on continue bien sûr toutes
choses étant égales 22 millions de
nouvelles filles femmes au niger en 2060
3 mais imaginez comment notre pays
serait transformée avec une armée une
armée effective de femmes éduquées
résiliente instruite entreprenante
éduquer ambitieuse vous imaginez ce que
ça donnerait la résilience pour nous
c'est maintenant il n'y a rien de
nouveau dans la résidence au niger il a
fallu que j'aille vivre en afrique
centrale pour me rendre compte
en fait on est extra résilient au niger
au niger il fait chaud on est un pays
aride
l'agriculture est compliqué la
pluviométrie n'est pas prévisible
il n'y a pas d'eau c'est très difficile
il ya du pays où la vie est beaucoup
plus souple je dirais ils sont gâtés par
la nature mais ça veut rien dire au nid
encore là on est encore là et on a de
l'ambition qui est encore plus que ce
qu'on a réussi jusqu'à présent
et donc cette résilience là on l'a déjà
je pense d'un autre des années de
nigériens ce que je vais
vous dire c'est qu'un ressort ma langue
on appelle résilience alfie olivier
saint-cricq alfie ça veut dire
résilience a donc on a même mon pour ça
dans une de nos langues ça veut dire que
ça nous définit tomber et se relever
entreprendre et échoué que ce soit un
entretien un examen une entreprise tous
à résider dans une université
tout ça ça nous demande d'être prêt à
accepter une défaite mais de pouvoir se
relever après cette défaite là c'est ça
qui définit notre résilience
je voulais l'exemple de 30 mois j'ai
quitté niamey en 1994 pour aller étudier
aux états unis
j'avais un bon job ici à niamey même le
planton de l'union européenne garde
reste soit il s'appelait à malam buba
telle mesure est une folle tu vas aller
étudier pourquoi
à 25 ans un bon job zhang à qui veut
épouser mon fils épouse et au final
c'est mon mari mais tu va l'étudier pour
faire quoi
là tu et à toi avec les européens ça se
passe bien pour toi tu as l étudier pour
faire quoi
mais moi je voyais que mon job à l'union
européenne étaient trop limités
j'imagine que je pouvais faire mieux que
ça je savais pas encore quoi mais
j'étais persuadé que je pouvais faire
mieux que de travailler ici à niamey
dans la délégation de l'union européenne
à une non européennes donc l'oqai n'est
ce pas et notre loyer locale je savais
qu'ils la livre alors que je fasse mieux
que ça et donc j'ai quitté niamey avec
le soutien de mes parents j'ai grandi
dans une famille
avec du savon moins atypique atypique
dans le sens où mon père qui est de
manille a eu une enfance graves ou des
années là gallas à aliev était quelqu'un
qui était absolument persuadé que les
femmes pouvaient tout faire donc moi
j'ai grandi avec le message tu peux tout
faire
intuit tu es tombé sur mon vélo national
à la barre pour a raté un examen de la
têt ne savait pas une bonne note c'est
pas grave tu continues tu es pas que
définie par un échec à rennes accident
donc je sais que ça ça m'a beaucoup
marqué donc ce qui m'encourage dans ma
vie de mère de d'instaurer ce même
message là les enfants et dans ma vie
professionnelle quand je suis allé à
finalement j'ai fait moins bien je me
suis retrouvé à wall street
et je me suis rendu compte que il
fallait absolument prêt dans ma
résidence que j'utilise toutes là moi
authentique que je suis je suis
nigérienne je suis africaine
je suis comme ça je suis chrétienne tout
ça me rendais complètement
incompréhensible à la classe mais comme
on appelle ça m'apporte grâce à ce
moment il me comprenait pas j'avais un
nom qui n'arrivait pas à prononcer je
refusais qu'on m'appelle c'est c'est eh
non vous savez lire vous allez dire
zohra il nous faut c'est pas compliqué à
peut-être beaucoup de hauts et aux huées
mais si vous savez lire vous pouvez dire
youssoufou et donc c'était vraiment très
un endroit qui m'as tu vois beaucoup
formés mais en même temps j'étais
absolument ancré dans la conviction je
pouvais aussi le faire j'étais la seule
nigérienne la page de la seule africaine
femmes dans ma classe nba j'étais la
seule africaine femmes
quand j'ai fait mon stage à
la semaine était la seule africaine oua
à travailler dans l'entreprise pendant
que j'étais là bas donc ça me donnait
aussi de la force et j'ai voulu aller à
amc lors du haut de ce jeu me sentais
spéciales m6 m'a dit non veut pas de toi
et il a fallu que j'appelais à amc huit
ans plus tard pour avoir un job
instantanément ce job qui m'a mis
ensuite à la banque mondiale et qui
m'amenait aujourd'hui à la fondation
d'un goûter où je travaille et je pense
quand je pense à ce n'est pas cette
partie là que je voudrais que vous
remplissiez
oui parce que en fait je pense que la
leçon pour nous tout le tout je parle à
mes soeurs nigérienne enfin mes soeurs
même celles qui n'ont pas digéré le
meilleur c'est que on est obligé de
vivre la vie qui est celle qu'on est
appelé à vivre
on peut pas suivre les stéréotypes
on peut pas toujours faire ce que les
autres veulent qu'on fasse moi on m'a
dit ne part pas marie toit d'un bon gars
tu as déjà fait des études
tu as déjà été aux états unis ça suffit
ils restent ici c'est beau oui c'est pas
que ça aurait été un mauvais choix de
rester sûr que moi je voulais faire
autre chose donc celles qui ont envie de
faire autre chose faut oser le faire et
le succès mais que la conséquence comme
tout le monde vous le dis tout le temps
de dead prez être prêt ça veut dire
excellent et de travailler bien tous les
jours surtout que ce soit des
photocopies qu'il faut faire que ce soit
des gérer le calendrier quelque chose de
des choses qu'on trouve pas valorisant
tu te les faire bien
ce bon travail là ouvre des opportunités
et maintenant ces opportunités là pour
d'autres et d'autres et d'autres et
c'est comme ça qu'on peut changer le
destin de notre pays
alors
alors si on revient à 6 22 millions de
femmes qui seront là en 2000 63,6
chacune d'elles pouvait avoir un
parcours un similaire au mien parce que
je suis pas un exemple moi mon exemple
les particuliers à moi mais un exemple
qui leur permet d'être tout ce qu'elles
ont la capacité de faire ça veut dire
qu'elle soit en bonne santé
éduquer former encourager imaginez le
niger qu'on pourrait avoir
merci
[Applaudissements]